[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Jay is
with us Jay is in San Diego hi Jay
welcome to the Ramsey Show hi thanks for
having me sure what's up so my wife and
I are currently saving up to buy a house
um and her grandma who she's very close
to just offered to give us a gift of
$30,000 to put towards the down payment
uh my question is is is it ethically
okay to take this gift knowing that she
has siblings cousins and uh her parents
who have not been given that same offer
of a
gift it's ethically okay um because it's
not your money it's her money she gets
to decide what she wants to do with her
money um and um but what you're pointing
out is is it may piss them
off right yeah and kind of justifiably
so come up yeah I mean cuz there's no
intention as far as you know for granny
to like give everybody the same amount
right yeah not not that we know of I
think she may but don't know for
sure yeah I don't think you I don't
think you have an Ethics problem but you
might have a relationship problem when
all this comes out to
light because feel people's not feelings
will be hurt really not by you but by
your grand by her grandmother right m i
mean you didn't do
anything yeah but uh um I mean I I I
maybe your wife needs to talk to her
grandmother and say hey what about when
so and so finds out and they're angry
about
this yeah so her grandma mentioned that
she would ideally like to keep it
private I just
know yeah but in my head it's a gift I'm
like yeah to Jay and I mean I think you
guys just have to be aware that if or
when this comes out it's going to come
out it's going to be awkward it's going
to come out when Granny's estate is
cleared
mhm so you're you know just be prepared
that somebody's going to have their
feelings hurt later but does that stop
him from taking the gift no I don't
think so um as long as you're willing to
you know be ready for your wife's sister
to be angry at her dead grandmother
someday right how many uh how many
grandkids are there like um there are
seven
okay has she I wonder if she's done she
wants to keep it private I know I wonder
if she's done other private money gifts
we don't know because it's private you
know I mean the surface that she had
helped out people with uh paying for
college that was supposed to be private
for some of the cousins but um that came
to to light
how um I think I think the the parents
knew um that Grandma was helping helping
out the grandkids and kind of the
parents talked and and so then all the
other grandkids had found out and they
did not get help then okay so granny is
not exactly worried about everything
being even which is Granny's prerogative
that's okay I don't mind that a bit um I
mean the only place there's fair is at
the tilt of whal and the cotton candy
right uh so Granny gets to do what she
wants to do with her money um you do not
have an Ethics problem but okay so how
did the cousins
however the cousins all reacted when the
parents talked and the word got out
about the college money that is a
predictor of how they're going to react
when this comes
out are you ready for that if you're
ready for that game on and the G and as
long as this is truly a gift and there
are no uh strings attached of any kind
it's not alone and Granny has doesn't
get to pick out the paint colors or
something she's not in control here of
your house purchase because of 30k if
there's no control freak stuff going on
no strings attached and you're willing
to accept the blowback that will look
similar to when the other gifts came to
light then that that's where you are
you're okay with that if it's not worth
30,000 for the drama then walk away
create your free every dollar budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life